let's start shall we with that 1.8
billion pounds of extra funding for the
Health Service presumably you welcome
that with open arms well we'll see if
this money is ever delivered over the
last two years a hundred and forty five
separate announcements for new beds new
equipments upgrades the buildings have
been announced by ministers totaling two
and a half billion and only a hundred
million of it has ever actually been
delivered its sharing competence on the
part of Matt Hancock the health
secretary look our hospitals are
suffering with from their ceilings
collapsing sewage pipes bursting cancer
patients waiting for diagnosis of have
their appointments cancelled because of
faulty equipment seriously ill mental
health patients at risk of suicide are
in old decrepit dormitory-style
wards and it's because Tory ministers
have done these smash-and-grab raids on
the investment budgets cutting over four
billion from those budgets and it means
today that our hospitals our NHS is
facing a backlog of six billion pounds
worth of repairs putting patient safety
patient lives at risk every day it's no
wonder the top advisors of Boris Johnson
says Tory MPs don't don't care about the
NHS so how much would labour spent on
the Health Service in additional funding
I mean the Health Foundation suggests
the figure of six billion pounds is
necessary is that one that you would see
well we had the last election said we
don't want to invest an extra 10 billion
pounds in the capital infrastructure of
our NHS we could have a general election
very soon the speculation in the
newspapers again today that the Tories
are preparing for a general election
that's what today's announcements all
about and if they're a general election
comes along in the next few weeks or in
the autumn then we will come forward
with a new funding settlement for the
NHS but what we are clear on is that
we're prepared to put more money into
our NHS so we can rebuild our hospitals
we can rebuild our doctors surgeries and
half of doctors say their surgeries it
at their local general practice
surgeries are not good enough so we can
buy the modern equipment so we can get
our cancer diagnosis rates much better
over 40,000 people wait beyond six weeks
we're diagnosis
it used to be three thousand people nine
years ago and that's because we've got
some of the lowest numbers of MRI
scanners and CT scanners in the Western
world is simply not good enough
these Tory cuts are putting lives at
risk and we have to put more investment
into the NHS you're not going to get it
with Boris Johnson on occasion the
Labour Party has been accused of
indulging their little bit of project
fear mongering I suspect people will
make that accusation today about the
latest pace of labour research which
suggests that signing a free trade
agreement with the United States could
see drug prices spiral out of control
it's not remotely squirming this is what
the u.s. his own health secretary has
said the US have said that they want to
force the NHS to buy American
pharmaceuticals American medicines more
expensive prices so a trade deal with
the u.s. not only will it mean more US
firms coming in to run sections of our
NHS so privatizing our NHS Hancock is
already allowing nine billion pounds
worth of contracts to go to the private
sector but it will mean the US
pharmaceutical industry forcing us to
buy more expensive drugs why would that
be any different under labor given
you're both going to have to sign the
same FTA no because we are not going to
sign a trade deal with the United States
that would allow the the u.s. to come in
buy up the new NHS and force the NHS to
buy pharmaceuticals from the US
pharmaceutical companies we are not we
are not going to smash up the regulatory
regime the nice regulatory regime that
we have in this country that's served as
well for many many years and which
allows us allows us to have
pharmaceuticals analysis of medicines at
reasonable prices the u.s. specifically
want a trade deal to force us to buy
more expensive medicines and it'll mean
the NHS forking out more for insulin for
asthma asthma medications for cancer
drugs I don't believe that's fair and
Tory ministers should rule it out today
what we should say at this point of
course that the government has on a
number of occasions said that the the
NHS it's not
for sale pal I wonder what suits cool so
this about pharmaceuticals though isn't
it this is about the pharmaceutical
industry and the US Secretary for health
specifically said he wants other
countries including the UK to pay more
the u.s. pharmaceuticals this will be a
red line in one of their trade deals and
that is why it's so important and why
we're raising it today I wonder if we
can turn our attention to what happens
in Brecon in in the by-election this
week this was not a happy hunting ground
for labour admittedly but given how long
this government has been in power given
the new leader and the popularity which
we keep hearing as attributed to him
from from senior Labour figures like
yourself why didn't labor turn not I've
been in roles in election campaigns yeah
all my political haha political laughs
for 20 years that by election very
quickly became a contest between the
Liberals and the Tory Party so it's not
surprising that the Labour vote would be
squeezed in there in that in that
by-election in fact I remember
by-elections when we were had it we're
in government and sorry I'm sort of
looking attacked by flats but I remember
by-elections when we were in sorry about
that
I remember by-elections when we were in
wearing government and we were going on
to win subsequent general elections
where the Labour vote was squeezed
significantly because the by-election
became a fight between the Liberals and
the Tory party that's not unusual in
by-elections unusual elections that
labour has fought recently Brecon you
drop your vote sure by twelve and a half
percent Peterborough you dropped it by
17 percent Newport West 13 percent in
2018 Lewisham nice you went down by 18
percent 2017 you dropped by 2 percent in
stock and 5% in Copland there is one
direction of travel in all of this and
it's entirely the wrong direction for a
party that says that it's ready for the
general election but in those
by-elections like Louis Sherman Newport
we held on and actually Peterborough
which was a Tory seat until 2017 a seat
that all the pundits and experts said we
were going to lose to the Tory party we
held on to that Peter Percy I mean that
was a Labour seat between 1997 and I
think 2005 so we lost it under the days
of Tony Blair we won it back in 2017 and
we held on to it
in a difficult by election which every
expert would and every time I came on
shows like this they said oh you're
gonna lose his Peter by election aren't
you it's the end of Labor and we held on
in Peterborough in a key marginal the
sort of marginal seat that would be the
which will be the electoral battleground
between labour and the Conservative
Party in the general election whenever
it comes I'm sorry I'm sorry to kind of
bang on about this point but there are
plenty of people within the partying
without the party you make the point
that Jeremy Corbyn has to have had a
rule in the poor performances that there
have been I mean your argument
essentially seems to be well we held on
surely that isn't good enough at this
point in the electoral cycle Pat glass
making the point on Twitter not that
long ago surely it's no time to wake up
smell the coffee and change the leader
what no no of course we shouldn't be
changing leader Jeremy Corbyn has been
elected by the party members and the
party members want Jeremy Corbyn to go
on and fight the next general election
when it comes I suspect it will come and
the art I'm certainly reading today's
newspapers it well and the reason that's
we don't need any division in the labour
party is that we've got Boris Johnson
who is who is who is a very right-wing
prime minister who is taking us out of
the European Union probably of a No Deal
you had a Treasury Minister on your
program last week saying we are
turbocharging
towards no deal no deal will be a
catastrophe for the National Health
Service if we catastrophe for our smooth
access to medicines when we import 37
million packs of medicine every month
from the EU it will be a catastrophe
for our economy we'll lose billions of
pounds worth investment we've seen in
the newspapers today that schools are
worried about the supply chain for
school dinners we might not get school
dinners is the big divide any British
politics politics but how are you going
to stop No Deal I mean if you look at
the papers this morning Dominic Cummings
and others are absolutely assured of the
fact that you've missed the boat in
terms of a vote of confidence
if the Labour Party's priority was to
stop nor deal why on earth didn't you
call the vote before Parliament before
Parliament rose for the summer recess
there'll be opportunities for us when
Parliament returns in September to stop
not you're not according no they feel
they feel that if a vote of confidence
were lost
there was an efficient
wiggle room with the Prime Minister's
discretion that they could call a
general election that would be after
they would call a general election which
polling day would be after October the
31st well let's look at let's see what
happens in September because the
government will have to bring forward
appropriate legislations refer for this
brexit No Deal exits that they want and
we will use all the means available to
us empowerment working across the
parties because we know there are plenty
of Tory MPs who want to block No Deal as
well particularly a lot of those who
Boris Johnson perhaps rather foolishly
in retrospect sacked from the cabinet
two weeks ago we're working with MPs
across the House of Commons and we will
work to stop No Deal Tory ministers are
turbocharging towards a No Deal that's
what the Treasury Minister said on your
program last Sunday and I think to push
us out of the European Union at the end
of October beginning of November on a No
Deal basis as we are going into winter
which is always a difficult time for the
NHS it's the height of irresponsibility
when we know our No Deal wrecks it would
be disastrous for the NHS it will put
lives at risk
that is the gamble that Boris Johnson is
taking this October November he is
playing with people's lives and he's
playing with the future of the NHS by
turbocharging towards a No Deal we are
just about to run out of time but I just
want to be absolutely clear about this
do you accept that you may have missed
the boat in terms of a vote of no
confidence that the times the time might
just not just might not be there for a
general election to take place before we
leave the European Union no I don't
accept that I don't agree with Dominic
Cummings analysis and by the way we keep
reading about what Dominic Dominic
Cummings says and doesn't say we know we
said that Tory MPs don't care about the
NHS he we've got that on the record why
do the Dominic Cummings just come out
and do interviews because every
newspaper seems to report what he's
saying at special advisers meetings in
number 10 yeah you know this guy who's
running Downing Street he wants to take
us out of the European Union with a
disastrous No Deal he believes Tory MPs
don't care about the NHS I agree with
him on that but I know that an NHS is
gonna be absolutely catastrophic for the
no deals gonna be catastrophic for the
NHS and he's putting patient lives at
risk
Boris Johnson is highly
sponsible by refusing to take it off the
table